[Music]
yes you will see that's well that's
exactly the symbolism of the Greeks like
reducing all hierarchy to to power you
know and and selfish power okay it's it
is utterly naive it's ignorant right so
I say education has to be totally
reconstituted including public education
to begin in the most distant past it so
that so our young people today who know
nothing about how the how the world was
created today and have it okay can
understand okay what marvelous paradise
they live in and it's the product of
capitalist is the product or product of
individual innovation it's the project
most of it's the product of a Western
tradition that everyone wants to trash
now is there if you'll beget in the past
and show it also talk about war maybe
with the more is the one thing that
wakes people up okay as we see war as we
may see yes okay war is the reality
principle my of the father and all in
five of my uncle's went to World War two
you know and you know my father was it
was part of the force that I Blandon in
Japan okay a paratrooper you know I
think at the time of the Japanese
surrender okay and my couple uncle's got
shot up and so on when you have the
reality of war when people exceed the
reality of the horrors of war Berlin
burned to a crisp and and so on your
starvation okay then you understand okay
and this marvelous mechanism that brings
water you know to you to the kitchen and
you slip on a lightly the electricity
the electricity I know of for me like
and I suppose it's because I have
somewhat of a depressive temperament I
mean one thing that staggers me on a
consistent basis is the fact that
anything ever works I mean because it's
so unlikely you know to to be in a
situation where our electronic
communications work where are where our
electric grid works and it works all the
time right it works a hundred percent of
the time and the reason for that is that
there are mostly men out there who are
breaking themselves into pieces
repairing this thing which just falls
apart all the time I said this in the
monk debate okay in Toronto several
years ago I said there's the invisible
all these CDs
you know leadest you know professors
sneering at men if men who are
maintaining everything around us or
anything this is an invisible army okay
which of you would you feminists don't
notice right nothing would work
regarding regard is impressive which is
you know and like a professor is someone
who's standing on a hill surrounded by a
wall which is surrounded by another wall
which is surrounded by another wall like
its walls all the way down who stands up
there and says I'm brave and independent
it's like you've got this protected area
that's so unlikely it's so absolutely
unlikely and the fact that people aren't
on their knees in gratitude all the time
for the fact that we have central
heating and air conditioning and pure
water and reliable food it's just it's
absolutely unbelievable used to die and
then the water supply they would admit
was contaminated with cholera for Evans
sakes a people can understand okay thank
had clean water and fresh milk fresh
orange juice all of these things there's
a mom and all of the time all the time
and that's in Western culture is heading
ok become because we are so dependent on
this on this invisible infrastructure
we're heading for an absolute
catastrophe when jihadists figure out
how to paralyze the power grid
the entire culture will be be chaotic
you'll have mobs in the street ok
you know within three days okay wait a
minute so suddenly the food supply is
interrupted and there's no like there's
no way to communicate they'll be like
we're the robber I mean that is the way
Western culture is going to collapse
okay it won't take much just single
point so silly because we are so
interconnected you know now we are so
it's so it's so dependent on
communications and computers they eat it
I used to preach for years it'll be an
asteroid hitting there yeah I know how
the solar flares work so back in this
happens about once every century so back
about 1880 and I don't remember the
exact year there was a significant
enough solar flare so that produces an
electromagnetic pulse like a hydrogen
bomb because the Sun is a hydrogen bomb
an electromagnetic pulse will emerge
from the Sun and wave across the earth
and it produces huge spikes in
electrical electrical current along
anything that's electronic and it'll
burn them out it let it lit telegraph
operators on fire in the 89
and one of those things took out the
Quebec power grid in 1985 and knocked
out the whole Northeast Corridor and so
they figure those things are about one
in a century event but those single why
how my brother-in-law who's a very smart
guy he designed the chip an iPhone we
were talking about political issues the
last time I went and saw him in San
Francisco and his notion was that all
that the government should be doing
right now is stress testing our
infrastructure the same way they stress
test the banks because we're so full of
these single points of failure that and
I think you're absolutely right luckily
we've been what would you call invaded
by stupid terrorists instead of smart
terrorists because a smart terrorist
could do an unbelievable amount of
damage in a very short period of time so
and it's just God's good graces that
that hasn't happened yet and so what
will happen is that it's the men
okay the men will reconstruct
civilization while the women cower in
the houses and have the men go out and
do all the dirty work that's what's
going to happen again only men will
bring civilization back again